instead of dark energy within the known
universe is there a chance something
Beyond is sucking to cause the expansion
of the Universe from Beyond in order for
that to happen there are two assumptions
you can make assumption number one is if
that were the case then that means that
our observable universe is just a little
bubble in a much larger universe and
something around the outside can
therefore create that kind of expansion
through suction the other situation
might be that if we as A
four-dimensional Spacetime were embedded
in a five-dimensional membrane you could
imagine that our
four-dimensional thing is expanding in
the fifth-dimensional thing almost
because of something say a surface
tension in the same way that say an oil
slick expands across across the surface
of the water surface of the water when
the it just keeps expanding no matter
what